my name is Emma Varga I'm presenting
research done with myself
dr. Kyle Keene and Professor Craig
Carter all of my teas materials science
department and my talk is on designing
nano structures that reproduce
particular structural colors
specifically using an adaptive mesh
search algorithm to do so
hello everyone my name is Emma Virgo and
today I'm presenting work I performed
with dr. Kyle Keene who's present and
Professor Craig Carter were all in the
material science department at MIT
and the project we worked on is
designing nano structures that reproduce
specific specific structural colors
using an adaptive mesh search technique
and if you're interested in this work
there is a mathematical available online
at github and there's also a paper in
the journal of the optical Society of
America but the problem we're really
interested in looking at today is how
these beautiful iridescent vivid colors
arise in nature not from pigments froth
from nano structures and the problem
were even more interested in is then how
do we design ourselves nano structures
like these that replicate the colors
that were specifically interested in and
so the phenomenon that were interested
in is called structural coloration and
it's a physical phenomenon that's
separate from most color that we see
around us which is derived from pigments
which are a chemical composition
structural coloration is the geometry of
the material itself contributes to its
color and so photonic structures are
composite materials they're made out of
two different materials with different
refractive indices and so as light
passes through interfaces between the
two materials light is going to interact
with that interface it's going to bend
and in turn different amounts of light
are going to interfere with each other
as they pass through and so this little
gadget here shows us kind of the concept
of interference so here we see that the
light waves coming off of the structure
are in phase and so the magnitude is
going to add and we're going to have a
very strong amplitude here but as we
increase the frequency and the
wavelength gets smaller the wave stopped
being in phase and they actually become
out of phase and so as we get towards
these green wavelengths we see that
these two waves here are actually going
to cancel out when they're added
together leading to a very low amplitude
and so already we get the intuition that
this particular structure is going to be
purple rather than green because we see
such a strong magnitude of those purple
wavelengths and this really is the
principle of structural coloration of
course as your structures get more and
more complicated
the patterns of interference are going
to become more and more complicated but
the general principle is the same and so
if we want a structurally colored
material we have two main requirements
first the material has to have a
periodic refractive index this generally
comes in the form of having two
materials that alternate spatially so
that you have the refractive index of
one and the refractive index of another
in a periodic way and this periodicity
also needs to be approximately the same
size as wavelengths of visible light and
so only c-collar we're seeing light that
is ranging in wavelength from 350
nanometers to about 700 nanometers and
so these nanostructures are on that
order generally about 100 nanometers to
a thousand nanometers possibly even
10,000 nanometers and this is so that
the interference phenomenon is occurring
in the range that we perceive as color
you can have the same phenomenon
infrared and ultraviolet but we just
don't appreciate it when it's happening
at those wavelengths and so we can
create synthetic versions of these
structural color materials in order to
do that we kind of need to understand
the relationship between color and
photonic structure and this is actually
a very complicated function even on the
most basic level from a number of
parameters first we care about the
optical properties of the materials so
their refractive index in this case of
the red material and the blue material
we need to think about the geometry of
the structure so is it one dimensional
two dimensional three dimensional is it
somewhat irregular the structure
features size and so even if we have
this one dimensional object if these
blue layers are 100 nanometers versus a
thousand nanometers there's going to be
a very different color produced and then
finally the viewers position so contrary
to pigment coloration structural
coloration is actually angle dependent
and we kind of get a sense of this if we
look at a peacock feather for example
and if you tilt it you know the color is
shimmery and it changes and this is the
angle dependence of structural
coloration and so then we can introduce
the inverse problem which is given a
desired color such as this blue color
here how can I design a photonic
structure that reproduces it and so in
order to solve this problem we need to
understand the relationship between
structure and
which you may already have a sense is
fairly complicated so first we can look
at modeling structural colors so how we
go from the geometry of our photonic
material to the color the simplest
possible structural material is a one
dimensional stack where you have
alternating layers of two different
materials and so in this case in order
to maintain periodicity all of the red
layers need to be the same thickness and
all the blue layers need to be the same
thickness though those thicknesses don't
necessarily need to be the same and so
two parameters we can play with is
thickness of the red thickness of the
blue in order to get different
structural colors and we can just do
that so in order to mathematically model
this one dimensional photonic crystal
here we can use a modified version of
Bloch's theorem black theorem is built
to deal with periodic media and we can
specify it to mean optically periodic
media and this model accounts for all
the parameters mentioned above so we can
change their affective indices and see
that the color changes as a result we
can change the width so the thicknesses
of these layers we can actually add
layers and that generally increases the
amplitude of a signal and then finally
we can change our angle with respect to
the photonic structure itself and so
this graph on the far side of this
visualization is very important it's the
reflectance spectrum so the way that the
material is reflecting light as a
function of its wavelength and the way
that I'm colored coloring it right now
is saying that the wavelength that is
reflected with the greatest amplitude
gives the color of this material but in
fact that's a gross oversimplification
the relationship between a spectrum and
its color is actually fairly complicated
and it comes down to the physiology of
the human eye and so if we're looking at
modeling spectrum into color we're
thinking about the XYZ color space which
is based on the way that our eyes
perceive color you have three different
types of color precepting cells in your
eyes the cones you have cones that
specialize with the longer wavelengths
the red cones you have cones that
specialize in the medium wavelengths
which would be the green cones and then
finally you have cones that specialize
in the shorter wavelengths with the blue
cones and as we change the
relative stimulation of these different
cone cells our brain is going to
perceive us as different colors and so
say that we're viewing an object and
it's giving off a particular effect
inspect riman to the eye the way that
our brain views color is that it fits in
these different cone cells using them as
basis functions to the photonic spectrum
itself and based on how much the
different wavelength areas are being
stimulated you're going to have a
perceived color in this case this blue
color here and so we see now that a
spectrum into a color is a terrific
compression of information you're going
from a continuous function into three
discrete values and somehow expecting
that to hold the same information which
is amazing so these visualizations here
each so two distinct color reflectance
spectrum that are perceived by our eyes
to be the same color and so the key
takeaway here is that when we're working
with color we can't use its reflectance
spectrum as a proxy even though it's
very tempting because it's Clini tative
it's a function we know how to work with
it mathematically when we're working
with color we really need to work with
color and we can't say a spectrum is
necessarily the same and so if we take
each combination of parameters in this
case the layer thicknesses of that one
dimensional photonic crystal and we take
the reflectance spectra that those
structures generate and then convert
that into a perceived color we can
visualize our parameter space in this
way so we can visualize it as kind of a
colored parameter space and so we see
that this is interesting it's a fairly
complicated parameter space even though
the structure itself is very simple then
we also see that very different
structures can give nearly identical
colors and sorry already I get a sense
that this is going to be a difficult
problem to solve because it's not a
simple mapping between a color to a
structure there's going to be lots of
options and so here is the inverse
problem given a desired color how can we
find a photonic structure that
reproduces it so our challenges are
going to be linking a single perceived
color to a single reflectance spectrum
it just can't be done and there's
infinite combinations of photonic
structure parameters the thicknesses the
materials the number of
the viewing angle and so really there is
no way to mathematically work backwards
we can't say here's our color here is
exactly the structure we need to
reproduce it and so instead of working
backwards we need to very efficiently
work forwards and this introduces the
need for an efficient search method so
as you saw before this parameter space
is interesting and the most interesting
and important part about it is that it
is smooth but the neighbors are similar
to themselves and you get information
same in this region I have a good sense
that I'm going to be a green color
because all the neighbors around me are
green and so this is in contrast to a
non-smooth parameter space where each of
these combinations of parameters would
give an independent color and so I call
this differentiability the parameter
space is continuous and smooth we can
think about it in the same way that we
think about differentiable functions and
this is great because then we can use
all of the wealth of tools that we have
to deal with differentiable parameter
spaces mathematically so long as we can
think of a way to consider colors in a
quantitative way so if we can quantitate
the difference between two colors give
that a number then we can work with all
sorts of search algorithms that have
already been developed and the way that
we do this is we work in the theoretical
L a B color space and so Li B color
space happens when you take colors that
we perceive to be opposites and you use
them to create three independent axes so
we have black and white blue and yellow
red and green and so every color that we
can perceive is going to fit somewhere
within this sphere of opposites and the
sphere has a radius of 0.5 and so the
maximum distance to objects can be
within the sphere is 1 and so we can use
Euclidean distance to quantify how
different two colors appear to ourselves
Mathematica is a color distance function
and so for example we can look at white
and black we expect this to have a color
distance of 1 which is the maximum and
it does if we want to look at Reds
distance between darkening shades of red
we can do that as well and we see that
the distance increases
and in fact it's a very nice linear
increase as we're moving down this axis
towards the black side of the parameter
or the LED color space and so now we
have a way to quantify how different two
colors are from each other which is
really the last thing that we need in
order to construct a search algorithm we
can also think about CIE Delta II star
color distance as a dartboard so say
you're trying to get red if you land
really close to the center you're going
to be out of color distance of about
0.05 which time I at least is pretty
much indistinguishable from red and as
you get further and further away the
colors that will be allowed are going to
be more and more differed from red and
as a threshold in commercial graphics
they say that colors are similar enough
to be perceived as identical if the
color distance is less than or equal to
0.06 and so I kind of use that as a
metrics for judging how good my results
are and so now we can introduce the
adaptive mesh search which is the way
that I decided to search through these
parameter spaces and the way I do this
is I take the parameter space and I fill
it with an evenly spaced mesh of points
I calculate the reflectance spectrum at
each of those points I convert that
spectrum into a color and then I use the
color distance function to measure the
distance between that color and the
color that I'm looking for I in this
case kind of this teal and so I do that
I calculate the set of color distances
and I choose the set that has the
closest color distance and then I use
these particular sets of parameters to
generate new meshes with a higher
resolution and then I repeat I calculate
all the color distances I choose the
best set I create a new mesh and I
continue until I have my set of good
enough color matches and so all of these
star stars represent parameter
combinations that will give a color
close enough to the desired color and so
we can look at results for this one
dimensional geometry here is a set of
randomly generated colors and here is
the match that I find after ten
iterations and at least to my eye these
are very good color matches this one at
the bottom here is a little dark but
otherwise they're practically
indistinguishable and this is validated
by the color distance squares
for the most part they're well under the
0.06 threshold and here is a schematic
of the convergence at each iteration so
these are the ten values we start with
across the entire parameter space and as
we iterate we narrow the selection into
a few spots with very good color matches
and even after only three iterations
we're well under the 0.06 threshold and
we have possible color space parameter
mixes that match the color variable and
so I mentioned that there is a package
we can see how that works now I'm going
to import it photonic system 1d is the
way that I'm representing the parameters
that are fixed so these aren't the ones
that I'm varying over and here I'm going
to actually choose in your color just
for fun and now we're going to try to
match it using a one dimensional
photonic crystal and so this iteration
is going to first spit out the
dimensions that give the best results
and so I see that if I have layers of
250 nanometers and then 150 nanometers
this is going to be one of the best
results in terms of matching this color
I see the colors of each of these
suggested dimensions the color distances
and then finally a visual representation
of the two colors side by side so here
my color distance is zero point zero
seven eight and I get the sense that I
have to iterate again at least a few
times to get a very good color match but
already this is fairly good and the
really great thing about this search
algorithm is that it's general enough to
be applied to any geometry to any set of
parameters as long as you're narrowing
and on those colors you want you're
going to end up getting good results and
so we can apply this to other geometries
and other mathematical models and so the
two-dimensional case is the photonic
lattice it looks like this the
simulation is a Fortran code called
unk's it was written by Ward and penury
and it gives solutions using fdtd
techniques and here are my results
here's my parameter space for the
two-dimensional case we see again it's a
differentiable
nice patterns and Fri generated 10
random trials I saw that my average
color distance was 0.06 to average
iteration time was pretty long about 11
minutes because it's such a complicated
calculation I can do this now with a
three dimensional case this is geometry
called a photonic glass it's actually
very interesting because it's um I
ordered rather than completely ordered
and so you can use statistical
techniques to model on average where
these spheres are going to be this
technique was developed by a lab at
Harvard and it's a combination of me
scattering for each individual particle
and a Fourier transform representing how
they're related to each other in the
matrix of the structure and I get
results I see that the colors that I'm
generating are fairly darker and I think
this is because the interfaces are more
complicated and more likely to
destructively interfere than they are to
constructively interfere but on average
my color distance is 0.08 so not bad
especially because I see that I'm
lacking a lot of bright colors and my
iteration time was a little over a
minute for each iteration and finally I
can apply the package to doing something
nature does very well which is structure
or color in natural materials such as a
butterfly wing so this is a swallowtail
butterfly and in nature this blue part
here is structurally colored but we can
try to structurally color the entire
butterfly wing so I begin with the image
here I use dominant colors to decompose
it into six main colors and then I'm
going to perform a search algorithm on
each of these six colors I see in the
butterfly wing and here are the results
of this I see that the blue matches very
well as I'd expect because blue and
nature is structurally colored the
yellow is an okayish match but not bad
and then finally the red is a very
terrible match and it's disappointing as
this may be it's actually a physical
result because there is no red
structural color in nature so I see that
my results are consistent with what I'd
expect and so in conclusion this method
returns fairly good results for a range
of different photonic geometries and
it's general enough to work for any
mathematically characterized photonic
systems so as long as you have a
function that can take in photonic
parameter
and output a reflectance spectra you can
search for colors using the adaptive
mesh search and as computational models
improve as we are better at
characterizing these systems the results
will improve with it so this the search
method isn't going to become obsolete
it'll continue to be useful and relevant
um if that thank you and I'd like to
open the floor for questions yes yeah
the photonic glass oh the Christmas tree
one that's like my favorite structural
color it's the Morpho butterfly wing
there are a few different models one of
them models it just as the one
dimensional so it says assume those
layers that's kind of the Christmas tree
are continuous and you can get a pretty
good model based on that but mostly I
just think it's cool but yeah there are
models for that I didn't try them though
yeah
I think it is a long wait order yeah
it's not quite as periodic it's semi
periodic and so you get kind of darker
colors yeah because after you can see on
this edge here it's already beginning to
get gray and on the sedge it's already
black so you're really kind of confined
to that visible wavelengths range of a
hundred to a thousand about but yeah I
saw that this is really the only area I
can find color it does extend a little
bit this way with the volume fraction
but that tapers off pretty fast too yes
I don't think so but I'd be really cool
it would be cool to like graph the sups
of them and see if there's any
transformation
yeah
so then you'd only need one and you'd be
able to find all the possibilities
that's super cool I'd love to look at
that yeah thank you yes yeah yeah so
this photonic glass you kind of see that
the colors aren't quite as nice but this
one's very easy to make because it
actually self assembles and so you can
buy spheres from like any chemical
supplier and centrifuge them down and
you're gonna have structurally colored
material just like that and then right
now there's photonic paints that are
trying to use structural color and then
some people are interested in reflective
displays so kind of like your Kindle or
your e-reader something with that with
structural color because it would have a
much higher battery life and the color
would be just as vivid yes
I really want to UM it's kind of
expensive to do nano fabrication so I
haven't yet but I want to just buy a
bunch of these spheres off the internet
and try it
yeah
I really want to try that yeah if you
try it let me know yeah the the package
is online so you should be able to use
it all right thank you very much
[Applause]